as promised The Terminator franchise
came back but it didn't arrive to the
kind of financial success that studio
Paramount Pictures was hoping for
Terminator dark fate the sixth entry
into the Terminator film series that
acts as a direct sequel to 1984
terminator and 1991 s Terminator
Judgment Day opened in theaters on
Friday November first two dismal box
office returns despite having James
Cameron back on board as a producer
Deadpool director Tim Miller behind the
helm Arnold Schwarzenegger and Linda
Hamilton in their respective roles as
the t800 terminator and the gun-toting
badass Sarah Connor and a host of
intriguing new characters in the mix
dark fate sadly lived up to its name
facing a dark fate by earning just
twenty nine million dollars domestically
and ninety four point six million
dollars internationally over its opening
weekend that's not good for a franchise
trying so desperately to redeem itself
something goes wrong this could be our
last chance oh yeah with a total debut
pull of 123 point six million dollars
Terminator dark fate hasn't come close
to recouping its reported production
budget of 185 million dollars which
doesn't include the cost of marketing
and distribution according to The
Hollywood Reporter this means that dark
fate could end up costing Paramount
Pictures skydance media and the now
shuttered 20th Century Fox more than 120
million dollars each company is said to
have financed 30% of the film's budget
which works out to about 55 point five
million dollars a pop the remaining 10%
of Dark fates production budget is on
the line at the Chinese conglomerate
Tencent holdings thr details the worst
case scenario for terminator dark fate
as costing its finance ears 130 million
dollars in the event that the film loses
its overseas traction and winds up
flopping a source close to the outlet
has indicated that the better case
scenario is that Paramount skydance fox
owner Disney and 10 cent may end up
eating only about 110 million dollars if
dark fake quote does have strong legs
offshore still variety reports that
Terminator dark fate is looking at a
worldwide take home of only 180 mm
- 200 million dollars and that the film
would be to earn around 450 million
dollars total just to break even it
would be simple to say the dark fake
tanked at the box office because critics
and fans absolutely hated it and think
it's a massive piece of garbage but that
would be a lie it seems a big reason why
Terminator dark fate tanked financially
isn't because everyone thinks the film
is horrible rather it appears that the
film that preceded dark fate the much
derided Terminator 3 rise of the
machines Terminator Salvation and
Terminator Genisys all of which dark
fate actually ignores we're so bad that
people aren't giving the new movie a
chance fewer people heading out to
theaters naturally means less revenue
and it looks as though this is the
situation in which dark fate is
currently stuck for some fans the fact
that Terminator dark fate is being
touted as a franchise Reviver might
instill in them a terrible sense of deja
vu after all 2015 Terminator Genisys was
also marketed as something of a breath
of fresh air to the struggling franchise
with Game of Thrones Emilia Clarke
stepping into the role of Sarah Connor
and wound up getting ripped to shreds by
everyone who saw it there's a strong
chance people are afraid dark fate is
just Genesis with different packaging
which really isn't accurate never seen
one like you before
almost human I am human just enhanced
which means I can rip your throat out if
you piss me off Rotten Tomatoes reviews
for Terminator dark fade are fairly
solid the film sits at a respectable 70
percent critical rating its consensus
Terminator dark fate represents a
significant upgrade over its immediate
predecessors even if it lacks the
thrilling firepower of the franchise's
best installments sure
some critics weren't super fond of the
flick but others found it truly
enjoyable like the wraps William Viviani
who said of dark fate quote this story
actually demands to be told and it gets
told with precision and skill for their
part fans liked dark fate better than
critics did the film's audience rating
on Rotten Tomatoes is clocking in at 84%
as of the making of this video
overall Terminator dark fate may not be
a mind-blowing piece of cinema or a
universal crowd-pleaser
but it isn't avoid
all cost awful it's a pretty good film
with pretty good ratings but regardless
of what dark fate has going for it
Cameron returning as a producer
Schwarzenegger and Hamilton back in
action a new story to tell passable
reviews it's still floundered at the box
office
unless Terminator dark fate somehow does
the impossible and earns an unthinkable
amount of money in the very near future
things aren't looking good for the
franchise what was intended to be a bomb
to help heal the film series may have
just made it even sicker and possibly
even pushed it to its doom check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the belt
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]